wird dieses jahr die physik auf den kopf
gestellt beim lg dem large hadron
collider am cern in genf wird noch im
laufenden jahr 2022 eine riesige
sensation erwartet die wartungspause von
drei jahren in der der beschleuniger
deutlich aufgerüstet wurde ist endlich
vorbei und der lfc wird schon bald
wieder auf hochtouren laufen aufhören
touren wird also schon bald eine
sensation aus genf gemeldet und wenn ja
welche genau pixum science im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen absolut bereit für
eine revolution der physik genauer der
teilchenphysik einer bislang unbekannten
naturkraft auf der spur und
möglicherweise kann genau diese noch in
diesem jahr von den forschungen am
teilchenbeschleuniger lhc entdeckt
werden das wäre tatsächlich eine
spektakuläre sensation denn dann stünde
endlich eins fest das standardmodell der
physik der teilchenphysik ist nicht
vollständig und beschreibt noch lange
nicht alles das wäre eine absolute
sensation
aber wieso nach drei jahren wartungszeit
soll der gigantischen
teilchenbeschleuniger large hadron
collider lhc am europäischen
kernforschungszentrum cern bei genf im
märz 2022 wieder hochgefahren werden ab
juni diesen jahres dann werden in dem 27
kilometer langen unterirdischen ring
wieder protonenstrahlen aufeinander
gejagt werden und das fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit
hierbei kommt es zur kollision
um zerfallsprozessen und genau mit der
hilfe dieser experimente erhoffen sich
die beteiligten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern bahnbrechende neue
erkenntnisse denn durch die aufrüstung
ist die leistungsfähigkeit des
beschleunigers selbst und auch die
leistungsfähigkeit der angeschlossenen
detektoren deutlich verbessert worden
was erwarten die fachleute also an
spektakulären erkenntnissen und welche
experimente sind geplant wie
wahrscheinlich ist eine neue physik
wirklich alles zu den großen plänen am
cern gibt es jetzt hier von mir
2012 war der große moment gekommen eine
absolute sensation eines der letzten
puzzle teile des standardmodells der
teilchenphysik konnte durch die zehn
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aufgespürt werden die rede ist vom
endgültigen nachweis des sogenannten
higgs bosons das bereits 40 jahre zuvor
theoretisch beschrieben worden war das
teilchen das anderen teilchen die masse
verleiht der llc simuliert unter anderem
die zeit kurz nach dem urknall vor rund
14 milliarden jahren die geburtsstunde
des universums die forschungsteams
untersuchen hier die kleinsten
bestandteile der materie die sogenannten
elementarteilchen dabei sind sie den
grundlegenden gesetzen des universums
auf der spur dazu sagt der cern
forschungsdirektor joachim mnich
natürlich ist es immer ein
erkenntnisgewinn wir versuchen zu
verstehen was die welt im innersten
zusammenhält wie die natur funktioniert
das sich aus der entdeckung vor 100
jahren die atome funktionieren das handy
entwickelt war damals ja auch nicht klar
die geräte und verfahren die bislang
aufgrund der erkenntnisse von cern
fachleuten entwickelt werden konnten
kommen beispielsweise in der medizin zum
einsatz unter anderem bei der
krebstherapie das letzte puzzleteil des
standardmodells der teilchenphysik wurde
also hier aufgespürt und final
nachgewiesen damit wäre die geschichte
eigentlich zu ende doch noch dieses jahr
wird das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik
möglicherweise auch genau hier wieder
zum wanken gebracht denn in einer der
forschungsanlagen dem sogenannten nfc
wurden im vergangenen jahr 2021
beobachtungen in den daten gemacht die
auf eine bisher unbekannte naturkraft
hinweisen könnten eine komplett neue
physik wäre somit notwendig denn beim
zerfall der sogenannten beauty quarks im
teilchenbeschleuniger 11 sie entstanden
mehr elektronen als millionen dazu einer
der beteiligten wissenschaftler mit esch
patel die potenziellen im blick sind so
groß dass diese ergebnisse das
aufregendste sind was sich in 20 jahren
auf dem gebiet gemacht habe es war eine
lange reise um hierher zu gelangen
konkret geht es beim fcb experiment
darum wie protonen zerfallen wenn sie
kollidieren die fachleute analysieren
hier ganz genau wie diese kernbausteine
im teilchenbeschleuniger mit hoher
energie aufeinander treffen dabei
entstehen kurzlebige elementarteilchen
dabei sind auch verschiedene quarks wie
das sogenannte beauty qual beim zerfall
dieses beauty quax entstehen entweder
zwei millionen oder zwei elektronen die
beide wiederum teilchen typ der neptun
sind dazu die fachleute der lsb
kollaborationen nach dem standardmodell
haben die verschiedenen laptop elektron
myon und auch die gleichen
wechselwirkung stärken das wird als
lektor universalität bezeichnet als also
klartext beim zerfallen vom beauty quax
müssten mit gleicher wahrscheinlichkeit
elektron myon entstehen doch genau an
dieser stelle wurde nun die asymmetrie
entdeckt tatsächlich gab es bereits in
der früheren vergangenheit hinweise
darauf dass die so genannte laptop
universalität verletzt werden könnte
doch die signifikanten der bisherigen
beobachtungen lagen um den wert von zwei
standardabweichungen also sigma also
längst nicht ausreichend um auf eine
neue physik zu schließen doch bei den
aktuellen analysen aus dem vergangenen
jahr stieg die signifikanz auf 3,1 heißt
also die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür dass
dieses ergebnis mit dem standardmodell
übereinstimmt liegt nur noch bei rund
0,1 prozent dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam das spricht für eine
verletzung der laptop universalität dies
ist die bislang präziseste messung
dieses verhältnis
doch in der teilchenphysik braucht es
fünf sigma damit es ausreichend ist für
eine offizielle entdeckung
möglicherweise
steckt hinter der verletzung der laptop
universalität eine fünfte kraft eine
wechselwirkung die die vier bislang
bekannten grundkräfte ergänzt diese
potenzielle fünfte kraft könnte wenn sie
denn dann tatsächlich existiert
unterschiedlich stark an das mühe und
das elektron koppeln oder wird die
verletzung der laptop universalität
möglicherweise durch ein bislang
unbekanntes
elementarteilchen hervorgerufen hier
käme das sogenannte repo quark in frage
dass gleichzeitig am laptop und quarks
koppelt dieses bislang noch
hypothetische teilchen könnte auch eine
erklärung dafür liefern warum die ladung
von protonen und elektronen gleich ist
natürlich abgesehen von einem
unterschiedlichen vorzeichen auf die
frage warum genau so wohl sechs quarks
als auch sechs lebt ohne existieren
könnte durch diese erkenntnisse
beantwortet werden genau diesem rätsel
können die zehn wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler also in den kommenden
monaten endlich nachgehen durch die
inventur sind sowohl beschleuniger als
auch die angeschlossene detektoren
deutlich leistungsträger die zahl der
aufgezeichneten kollision dürfte nach
oben gehen dazu forschungsdirektor
joachim mnich wir bekommen zugang zu
prozessen die sehr selten sind je früher
die zahl an kollisionen desto genauer
ergebnis muss das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik also verworfen werden der
wissenschaftler ist optimistisch dass
die forschung des kerns auf genau diese
frage schon bald eine antwort geben kann
wir hoffen dass wir die frage ob das
real ist oder eine statistische vater
morgana in den nächsten zwei jahren
klären können das wäre eine sensation
wir hätten dann zum ersten mal in klaren
beweis dass das standardmodell nicht
vollständig ist nicht alle phänomen
beschreibt doch auch in einem weiteren
forschungsbereich werden spannende neue
erkenntnisse erwartet ein neues
zeitalter wird auch bei den anti materie
experimenten erwartet in der
wartungsphase wurde deswegen auch der
entschleunigung elena gepinnt das steht
für extra low energy antiproton ring
seit etwa fünf jahren werden
antiprotonen hier so verlangsamt dass
sie besser eingefangen und beobachtet
werden können im visier der
forschungsteams ist die gravitation die
auf der ebene der sub atome eine
schwache kraft ist und somit schwer
nachweisbar mit der hilfe von elena soll
beispielsweise geklärt werden ob
antimaterie wie normale materie nach
unten fällt oder gar nach oben doch erst
einmal muss der beschleuniger jahr
hochgefahren werden eine deutlich
größere sache und zeit aufwendigere
sache als man annehmen mag dazu joachim
mich es ist ja nicht wie beim auto
schlüssel umdrehen und los geht's zwei
monate wird das hochfahren in anspruch
nehmen und die gefahr besteht dass
kleinste fehler zu sehr großen schäden
führen im juni diesen jahres 2022
rechnen die forschung dann mit den
ersten teilchenkollisionen um weitere
große sprünge zu machen steht dann
langfristig die entwicklung noch
stärkerer magnete auf der agenda diese
sollen die protonenstrahlen an den
koalitions punkten noch stärker
fokussieren prototypen wurden zwar
bereits entwickelt diese müssen aber
noch weiter optimiert werden um alle
qualitätsmerkmale zu erfüllen doch in
der zweiten hälfte des jahrzehnts soll
dann am cern die sogenannte high lumi
phase starten durch einen weiteren
ausbau könnte der beschleuniger dann
fünf bis zehnmal mehr protonen
kollisionen pro sekunde als heute
ermöglichen damit entstehen auch mehr
daten die für eine auswertung zur
verfügung stehen und auch noch weiter in
die zukunft gedacht könnte das cern
weltweit weiter von sich reden machen
für die 40er jahre gibt es bereits ein
konzept für einen noch größeren
beschleuniger angedacht ist ein ring mit
100 statt der bisher 27 kilometer länge
seit dem vergangenen sommer laufen die
machbarkeitsstudien weltweit sind auch
japan und china ganz weit vorne mit am
start möglicherweise wird also auch hier
zuerst die sensation um eine neue physik
gelüftet vor drei jahren war ich ein
kämpfer und habe vom beginn der arbeiten
berichtet der large hadron collider hier
am cern wird zum super beschleuniger da
gibt es noch mehr details über die
aufrüstung des lfc also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran